[Music]
up next on book notes
meetings and loan situation with martin
mayer author of the greatest ever bank
robbery the collapse of the savings and
loan industry
mr mayer shares his thoughts on the
deregulation of the thrift industry as
well as his observations of those
involved in the current savings and loan
situation
[Music]
martin mayer
author of the book the greatest ever
bank robbery the collapse of the savings
and loan industry
on page 308 this sentence jumped out at
me when i read your book
a little thing like 500 billion will not
stop washington from doing business as
usual especially if the business is
technical enough not to interest the
producers of the nightly news what is
that all about
well i then give a list of little favors
that have been done to people in this
context
um
since all of this scandal came out
one would think that they would that
they would stop i mean
we have an example
recently of the federal national
mortgage association putting into the
department of housing and urban
development
a request
to do something with a bunch of snls
which would have involved these snl's
getting some cash money up front which
the owners could put in their pockets
and taking a loss on the sale of paper
which they wouldn't have to show as a
loss on their books but which they could
show on as a as a loss in their return
to the irs very cleverly designed
designed by an agency the federal
government really i mean partly it's
privately owned but there are five
directors appointed by the president and
it's supposed to have a social purpose
so here you've got
an agency of the government in effect
doing something which is legal it's
legal we got some very dumb laws still
but which is directly contrary to the
public policy of the s l bailout bill
bad as that bill may be in its part
there was a an intent in that bill and
here is an effort federal national
mortgage association to circumvent the
intent of that bill to encourage once
again fraudulent bookkeeping at snl's
and this is now more than a year after
presumably there was a bailout in after
scale incidentally the letter of
submission to hud said that this should
be kept completely secret and not even
available through freedom of information
act request because it had it had pro
proprietary competitive to proprietary
data that might be of value to
competitors i mean this sort of sleeves
sleeves from
from an agency of the government um i
don't know how you stop it now camp
stopped it by the way kemp wouldn't give
it to them kemp is the regulator um
but
it it's constant this place sells
influence it sells ways to get around
the law it writes the laws and then
sells ways to get around
and i find that's what's really
disturbing to me about this whole story
is the involvement of people who are
presumably leaders in their professions
leaders in their occupation
uh in finding ways in which you could
help crooks find a corner of the law in
which you could say that what they were
doing was not against the law we're
dealing with people who lead great law
firms four five six hundred loyal law
firms great accounting firms thousands
of accountants who will work with a
crook a man that they know to be a crook
i mean somebody like david paul at
center i said any question when you met
david paul wouldn't trust him around the
corner um
and and that they would they would
help this guy
because he was willing to pay their fees
which were enormous fees and because
they could find a way that what he
wanted to do could maybe be on the
penumbra of legal
that's disgusting that's the worst part
of the story not that they were cowboys
who stole money not that they were
congressman who took money but that
people in wall street investment houses
law firms in the
accounting firms made themselves
unindictable co-conspirators because
there was money in it for them and not
only that used every ounce of political
influence they had to prevent congress
from cleaning up the mess that had been
made in 8182 when the government was
trying to solve a problem took the wrong
step and then because so many people
were making money out of the
government's mistake you couldn't change
it year after year
that's what's shocking about i don't
know whether i counted right but i think
i counted 22 books of fiction a
non-fiction three books of fiction
that's probably roughly right that's 25
this makes you 26 books that's probably
right yeah including i've helped people
write memoirs my name isn't on them
because they are responsible for them
and i'm not but i've not been an
invisible ghost i've been thanked for
help
um rudolf bing of the metropolitan opera
and saw linowitz here and george moore
who was the first head of city corps
worked with them on memoirs you know
that's what i do for living i write okay
that's what i wanted to ask you because
there's some some things that you did in
this book you talk about that i want to
ask you about
are you basically a writer oh yes no i'm
i'm trained in economics as far as this
book is concerned i wrote a book called
the bankers in 1975. i wrote a book
called the builders in 1978.
david stockman read them and when the
reagan team came in they asked me to
join the housing commission the national
housing commission they were setting up
to investigate housing programs we were
you know we were suckered the aim of
this was to was was to cut the housing
budget and we all thought we were going
to design a new housing program they
were very decent guys on this thing i
think they were all republicans except
me
um but they were all people who wanted
to do something about housing whereas
the people who would put us up to this
really just wanted to cut the budget and
they succeeded they really gutted the
housing program so we were we were
suckered
but i was there when these regs on the
snl's were first being written and i was
conscious that there was a problem from
the beginning but it never occurred to
me that our system was so inflexible
that having made these mistakes and
would be unable to correct them
you said that you were the only one that
wasn't a republican does that make you a
democrat
i'm yeah i'm i'm a registered democrat i
had been a registered independent i may
have been a registered independent when
they when they put me on the housing
commission i mar i
my wife died i remarried i remarried an
ardent democrat so i registered
democratic i don't think she would have
married me if i wasn't a registered
democrat do you consider yourself to be
a political person i consider myself to
be pretty particularly in this book i
think i'm pretty thoroughly non
non-partisan they're they're you can't
prefer one party over the other in this
story they both misbehaved abominably
that's one of the reasons that never
became a a political issue because each
of them was scared of what the other one
would be able to say about them if they
if they made it a political issue there
are a lot of people you talk about let
me just ask you about one um dick pratt
yeah um
prat
richard pratt is the most able man was
ever chairman of the federal home loan
bank board he came into the federal home
loan bank board which was the body that
charted snl's and also owned and
operated the federal savings and loan
insurance corporation which insured
people's deposits and s
he came into it at a time when the
industry had a terrible problem he very
cleverly designed a number of accounting
devices he and his his friend is general
counsel tom vitanian and some of the
accountants around the bank board
they designed a system by which this
industry could pretend it was making
money when it was losing money and this
was done while i was hanging around here
a lot of these regs came over my desk
and as early as december 81 i i printed
in the book i wrote a slightly
disjointed piece for a magazine called
sin and sir in which i said we are
encouraging all these guys to lie about
the condition of their institutions
given that the interest rates are up to
16 17
it may be necessary to do that now if
they tell the truth about their
institutions then they'll be the only
people who do that if the interest rates
stay there we're all broke anyway so
there may be some excuse but let's
remember what we did it was going to be
very costly in retrospect this was a bad
idea off the top if you were going to do
what you should have sunset all of these
regs and had them end at a time certain
so that you weren't piling up
exponentiating the losses in this
industry um
and but even so i mean in fairness to
the world pratt pratt left full of the
odor of accomplishment dick is a very
good guy and he's i'm sure he's furious
with me um let me go back before you get
into i ask you just a couple of little
questions it turns a little bit federal
home loan bank board right he ran that
he was the chairman of the federal home
loan bank which had been a professor
university of utah 1981 1982. how did it
enter into the spring of 83. okay you
told us a little bit of what that does
how many members are on that board three
who appoints them president is it does
it still exist no it was it was put out
of business by the
wife
berea the financial institutions
reorganization regulation enforcement
agency something like that the act that
was passed in august of 1989 there is
there is now something called an office
of thrift supervision which is part of
the treasury department just as the
office of the control of the currency is
part of the treasury department the
office of thrift supervision charters
and regulates savings and loans the
office of the comptroller and the
currency charters and regulates banks
okay i hate to keep doing this but in
the beginning of your book you list what
fannie mae freddie's got
hoping to bring people if not up to
speed you know up to cruising in this in
the in these waters anyway i want to
dwell on it but the federal home loan
bank board was physically located here
in washington yes indeed
under what department at that point it
was it was an independent agency of
government like the federal deposit
insurance corporation
um
and it uh it
owned
the federal savings and loan in
insurance corporation the three
directors of that
the
the the three board members of that were
the three members of the federal home
loan bank board and it also owned the
federal home loan mortgage corporation
which packaged mortgages and into
pass-throughs and sold them through
these were all under the bank board
all right the bank board
got its three members by the president
president appointed them they had to be
approved by the congress they had to be
approved by the congress
how old was the federal home loan bank
board it goes by it's a it goes back to
the roosevelt era and i guess it's 34
uh was the was the first appointment of
the federal home loan bank board it grew
out of the homeowners loan corporation
and various ways to try to keep the
lenders to housing alive during the
early years of the depression you said
that the federal savings and loan
insurance corporation was under that's
right okay that's all for sorry also
called physics
all right i beg you where did fizzlick
get its money to ensure the savings and
loans
fizzlich got its money by a premium
charge on the savings and loans
themselves it also had a line of credit
of 750 million dollars at the treasury
if it ever had to borrow money in theory
that was all the resources it had
um when i was on the housing commission
and the snl's were losing money we got
very scared and we went to congress we
said we'd better have people believe in
this so let's get a bill through saying
that the full faith and credit of the
united states has pledged to the
insurance of these deposits because in
fact it is and we don't want people to
get scared and we got a sense of the
congress resolution to that effect we
did not get a law
um
but the the
it had begun insuring deposits up to 2
500
uh in 19 in early 1980 the ceiling was
40 thousand dollars in march 31st 1980
uh the congress passed a law which
raised that to a hundred thousand
dollars and one of the interesting
aspects of that law is that that raise
in the deposit insurance minimum and the
insured deposit maximum rather was was
not in either the house or the senate
bill coming into conference it was added
in conference
at the at the the motion of alan
cranston and the california snl page 20
of your book deposit insurance has
proved to be the crack cocaine of
american finance yeah why
because
let's let's take let's take a look at a
universe of banking and snls without
deposit insurance when a guy begins to
go under anybody with any brains gets
his money who knows anything gets his
money out of that institution before
1980 even with deposit insurance
any institution that got in trouble
would get smaller because a there'd be
people who had money in it over the
deposit insurance maximum who would be
in danger would take it out and b
there'd be people who say this is a
failing bank i don't want to have my
money in a failing bank even if the
government will pay me back in the case
of snl it wasn't an immediate payback
either so you even had a financial
reason even though you're going to get
your money um
and the government controlled the
interest rates that these guys could pay
to get deposits so that if if if an
institution began to go bad
it would get smaller there was a kind of
immune system to
the banks and the snl that when a guy
got sick he got smaller and therefore
the threat to the deposit insurance fund
was limited
you went in 1980 and 1982 and you freed
up the interest rates that they could
offer you'd say you could offer any
interest rate and the government would
pay it
if other people were paying seven
percent and you said i'll pay nine
percent you could get money from them
you could get money from the from from
the public easily you could also pay a
commission to a broker to bring it in
who freed up the interest rate
1980 1982 the first was the depository
institutions deregulation and monetary
control act in nineteen years congress
did it oh yes congress did it the second
was the gone saint-germain act in 1982.
those two the first of them said that we
are going to decontrol interest rates
set up a committee of regulators to do
it gradually over seven years the second
of them said do it now just free them up
all right let me go back to the
connection here on the garn
saint-germain act
jake garner senator from utah chairman
of the senate banking committee at that
time at that time when the republicans
had control
freddie st germain democrat chairman of
the house banking committee right now
he got in some kind of trouble he didn't
get returned to congress for some reason
or other why is that well
because he had taken advantage of his
position as chairman of the banking
committee to make himself quite a rich
man on interest-free loans from from
people who had banks who were regulated
by regulators who were subject to
freddie saint-germain's authority there
were there were a number of stories in
the wall street journal the house ethics
committee investigated they gave him a
slap on the wrist but the people of his
district decided they were sick of it uh
and he was one of the few congressmen in
recent years to lose one of the stories
that is that is told about this which i
tell him the book
is that when he knew he was a loser when
the polls came in saying that he was a
loser he pulled all of his television
commercials for the last week of the
campaign and kept the money because he
was one of those guys elected before
1980 who could do that legally all right
senator garin has he ever been accused
of taking i've gone to my mind god's a
decent guy to the best of my knowledge i
have i have um yeah the the thing that
they say about going around the senate
he's he's the space senator he cared
about that he's the one who went up in
the space shuttle some of the people who
work for him say he never came down um
he's a slightly spacey senator we have
others it's there's no harm in having
slightly spacey senators uh the thing
that if you if you read through the
record of the various hearings which
gone has participated what you see is a
guy who is in fact pure in heart whose
understanding of these matters is not
that great but there's worse um
and who wound up sponsoring things which
he later did not wish to believe had
made the trouble they made
when you when you talk about
congressman
taking money and doing things go on
didn't do that but you talk about some
of these other guys
i'm i'm i'm a part-time music critic and
years ago sally iraq used to send all of
the music critics two little two ounce
jars of caviar at christmas and a bottle
of vodka
and martin feinstein who runs the
washington opera now was that his good
good old old friend was then europe's
press guy
and he said to your rock once mr eurock
do you really think that you can buy a
good review with two little two ounce
two eyes of caviar and your ex of course
not of course not but there's two ways
to write a bad review etc and that's
right and so people make gifts to
congressmen doesn't mean that they're
going to buy their support but it does
mean that they're going to get a
different kind of hearing when they come
in with a problem so now you get the s l
situation and you get them buying the
best accounting firms to certify
dishonest books let's be blunt about at
the snl's to apply accounting practices
which the american institute of
certified public accountants has said
okay but the financial accounting
standards would have said no way this is
a dishonest presentation um there are
people who are leaders you would think
they would follow what the standards
board says but if they didn't have to if
the practice contradicted the theory and
the practice benefited a charlie keating
or a david paul or a michael wise or or
a tom spiegel or all of these guys who
looted these snl's for all of that money
they would go along with them so then a
spiegel or a wise or a keating or a paul
would come to the congressman and he
would say the regulators are picking on
me and here arthur young or ernst and
winnie or arthur anderson or or cooper's
and lybra all of these or two schwarz
all of these are implicated firms i mean
i give chapter and verse in the book of
the institutions that they that they big
respected accounting firms big the great
accounting firms of the world not just
of this country so so so this
swindler would would come in with a
statement certified by a big eight
accounting firm he would be represented
by one of the nation's great law firms
paying the guy involved 400 an hour to
do it and he says to this congressman to
whom he's making a contribution these
stupid regulators are misinterpreting
the law and pushing me around you've got
to help me now
later when it turns out the regulators
were right and these guys were crooks
the congressman is in terrible trouble
but if you move him back to that moment
in time and if you read the transcript
of the of the meeting of the keating
five with the san francisco people you
have deconcini for whom i have no
sympathy because deaconcini later on did
things for keating which are disgraceful
but at that moment he said we have this
statement from arthur young this letter
from arthur young senior accountant in
phoenix saying that all of this is okay
how do you account for that would a
great accounting firm prostitute itself
and mike patriarca from the san
francisco home loan bag said they do it
every day
but this but for his congressman or a
senator to realize that these people
whose names he respects and years ago
would have been right to
respect
are prostituting themselves
judge judge sporkin castigated the law
firm of kay scholler from the bench here
keating had sued to get his
snl back i mean that joke lawsuit
and spoken took it all seriously being a
man of a sense of humor and heard all
the evidence and then at the end he
ruled that that of course this this
improvidently run and essentially
crooked snl was properly seized by the
government but at every step in the way
this 400 plus lawyer law firm nationwide
headquartered in new york very
distinguished people in it had council
keating had helped him do all of this
and spoken excoriated them from the
bench and a spokesman for this law firm
said then
not to me this is something i took out
of the papers but i'll assume the papers
are accurate we we did only what the
client asked us to do
boys are not allowed to make that
defense
why should a great law firm think that
that is a defense for having done what
they did
federal home loan bank board uh we go
back to the beginning right
uh
dick pratt former university of utah
professor subsequently chairman of
merrill lynch mortgage capital moved on
afterwards after the federal home loan
bank moved on and made a lot of money
yeah i want to talk about him in just a
second but also ed gray was ahead of
that operation ed gray succeeded pratt
in the spring of 83. who succeeded ed
gray danny wall who succeeded danny wall
well danny danny wall became the first
head of the office of thrift supervision
when the system was reorganized and was
then forced out essentially by the house
banking committee and there's a man
named timothy ryan who is who is now the
head of the office of thrift supervision
the reason i'm going through this is i
want to get back and talk about dick
pratt ed gray and danny wall and so we
can get some sense of how as we watch
speaker wright leave office over the
relationship with ed gray and all that
kind of stuff we get some sense of it
dick pratt again what what did he do
when he was in that job because by the
way you say in your book
you blame him for this whole snl crime i
say if you're looking for any one person
to blame more than any other one person
it's got to be pratt why because he
wrote the regulations in other words my
the basic position of this book
is that all of this was facilitated by
the change in the accounting procedures
of this industry which pratt instituted
in 1981 and 1982. savings alone of the
savings and loan industry plus other
things for example when pratt came in to
get a deposit insurance charter you had
to have either be a mutual institution
i'd have at least 400 shareholders and
nobody could control more than 25
percent of the stock pratt removed that
restriction
um when pratt came in you couldn't have
more than five percent of your deposits
as brokered deposits you had to have
them coming in from real people at
teller windows pratt removed that
restriction
you couldn't play in the options and
futures markets before pratt came in
pratt wrote regulations which permitted
these guys to play in the options and
the futures market i list them the best
list is in a book by a guy named ed kane
who's a professor at ohio state book
published by the urban institute who has
page after page of the change in the
regulations which eliminated the immune
system of the industry
um
and now what pratt will say
is that you know these were regulations
they could have been changed later we
never intended this to be permanent he
just testified before the house banking
committee and said we never intended
these changes to be permanent when the
industry when the interest rates came
down they were all to go away but the
fact of the matter is that when gray did
try to change them uh pratt led the
charge against the changes um because he
was then working with merrill lynch and
merrill lynch was making a fortune out
of the sms you also point out that don
regan
chief of staff to ronald reagan former
merrill lynch ceo was in this mix did he
ever do anything wrong ed gray says
and the people around gray say
and pratt
doesn't quite deny
that at one particular crisis moment
when american savings and loan of
stockton which was the nation's largest
snl
30 billion dollars big institution was
going to go under
and they really had to raise money to
pay back the people who wanted their
money out
uh pratt agreed to put a billion dollars
of merrill lynch customers money into
american savings and loan cds
and
after talking to don regan he backed
away from it i do not know this as a
fact um but
but there's no question that merrill
lynch had been expected to put in the
money that merrill lynch backed away at
the last minute in the phone call from
pratt to gray and that the bank board
then had to reach george ball at
prudential beach in spain where he was
on
vacation to get a billion dollars of
prudential base money in there there's a
book coming out by a nice guy named
michael robinson who was the american
banker san francisco man uh which is a a
story of
of american savings and alone it isn't
out yet and uh he tells this story in
some detail i tell it in the page or two
here
uh i believe that don regan probably did
interfere at that moment and then later
on he was then secretary of the treasury
later on when he became regan's chief
reagan's chief of staff there's no
question that he belligerently
interfered with the operations of the
bank board and tried to prevent
uh the bank board from withdrawing the
regulations out of which these guys were
making so much money
26 books
yeah i guess which one sold the best
the bankers was a was a book of the
month club main selection
um what year
1975
and they distributed 160 000 copies and
about 80 000 sold in the bookstores and
then valentine brought it out in paper
and sold half a million that's the one
that sold the best the one that sold the
best in the bookstores alone was the
lawyers in 1967. what was your favorite
book to write
um
i you know
i i you mentioned i was a part-time
music critic i remember when colin davis
had been a horn player chris became the
conductor of the bbc symphony i knew him
a little and i interviewed him for a
column i was then writing an esquire
magazine and he said he was going to do
the four brahms symphonies which he'd
never done he'd been playing in an opera
house orchestra
and i said do you like the brahms
symphonies and he said to me that's your
business
he said i play them you decide whether
you like them or not
and i write for a living i i enjoy
writing most of the time i enjoy the
information gathering and the analysis
even more really
this book is is is unique for me though
because i've never come out of a book
with with the emotional feelings about
what i was writing about that i have
with this one this is a great disgrace
it says things about my country that i
don't like to believe
um
it says things about people whom i would
like to respect that i don't want to
believe
uh i i think this is a uh this this
story is a terrible story terrible story
about the way we run this country are
you worried i'm worried that's that's
right worried i guess is also i have i
have kids in two generations i have kids
who are 35 32 nine and six
and the nine and six year olds going to
be paying for this and my grandchildren
are are going to be paying for this and
it was totally unnecessary
and it was because of the piggishness
of
people who
should have some feeling of
responsibility for this society
i don't blame the cowboys cowboys are
cowboys
um jerry good but adam smith has a piece
of film it shows a grizzled text a big
texas hat
and he's saying look he's
got a fox and a hen house get a lot of
dead chickens
doesn't mean that's a bad fox what a fox
gonna do in a head house you would have
somebody keep the fox out of the house
you let a builder own an snl he'll cover
the earth with buildings he doesn't care
if they sell
well he he needs financing so he can
build
you set the world up so he has free
financing from the snl he owns
and there's no end to the building but i
don't blame him he's not a bad man
that's what he does
we're supposed to have regulations that
keep these guys from owning these and
that's true so that when you when you
complain about the don dixons of this
world or even the charlie naps all of
the you know even the
heating's a separate story heating's a
great con man that's a different game um
and and paul maybe too but a lot of
these guys have cost the public a lot of
money it was their nature i don't blame
them
some of the things that happened in
congress that's the way the world works
i don't blame them but people who are
professional people who presumably have
a code that says you're supposed to
behave better than me illegality
their collaboration and cooperation
that's what scandalizes and shocks me
where'd you grow up new york city yeah
my father was a lawyer
um
my father started life in one of the big
wall street firms i wrote a biography of
the guy who was his first boss
at the request of felix frankfurter who
had been this guy's best friend um
and you know what was always true
that there were feet of clay in a lot of
these idols and a lot of guys who were
the senior partners of wall street
houses in the 10s and 20s and 30s did
things they shouldn't have done
but
nevertheless the judgment leadership in
the profession
was whether somebody embodied the
whether somebody embodied the ideal of
that profession and and spoke to what
people wanted to think of themselves as
members of that profession
you were a leader you had an obligation
to set standards today you get to be a
leader in a profession by having the
highest fees that's a terrible loss to
this country where'd you go terrible i
went to harvard what'd you study
economics
i was i i was there in the great days i
had courses with joseph schumpeter and
wassily leonief was my tutor but i got
out very early i didn't like education
terribly much and i
finished harvard before my 19th birthday
um graduated yeah
that's a good question no i was i was in
trouble and it wasn't until i was about
20 that i actually got my diploma
but i had finished my full i had
finished the full program except i
hadn't passed my language requirement
yet i went out and learned italian in
order to get a degree but i did not
actually graduate
until the spring of 48 i guess when i
was 20. but i finished in january of 47
just before my
19th birthday i took my last
exam at harvard other than the language
what year did 1940s write your first
book
the first book well i wrote a couple of
novels that nobody published and a good
thing too i'd be pretty embarrassed
the first books came out in 55. there
was a novel called the experts and there
was a book called wall street men and
money
which was kept in print
for another 18 years by collier books
boy was it out of date when they finally
jumped it it was a great title it wasn't
my title it was tom morgan's title did
you know uh even though you got a degree
in economics that you were going to
write for a living
well
i guess so i mean i began writing
a good friend of mine and i in fourth
grade put out a newspaper on my father's
mimeograph machine and i was always
editing school papers and i was on it
was the harvard service news when i was
first there but then the harvard crimson
again toward the end of my time
and my first job out of out of school
was the new york journal of commerce
which was going to combine the economics
and the writing i had thought for a
while i was going to be an economist
but
professor leontieff said to me one day
you don't use mathematics to solve
problems
i said what do you mean he said you
decide what you want to say and then you
find equations that say it
and i said of course does anybody do
anything else and he said yes he said
but what you're supposed to do is set up
the problem mathematically and solve it
mathematically and i that had never
occurred to me and i suddenly realized
was i couldn't do that i i've been very
lucky there were things that i was
tempted to do where somebody pointed out
to me you're no good
so i didn't do it
and then back in the early 80s the
ronald reagan's housing commission yeah
you served on that for how long i was a
commissioner it was a one-year
thing and and you know it was we met in
the year counting the subcommittees and
the finance committees and such things i
suppose i put in a total of 40 days and
then i read i mean i wrote the executive
summary
that was that's a great that's a
washington story
um
no you served you you got paid 200 a day
for the time actually spent
in meetings i mean the reading that you
did and other things that you might do
in connecting with the commission you
didn't get paid for it was it was not a
good investment of time um
but i wanted to to do it was interesting
and useful experience and one thought
one was being helpful to one's country
first time you'd ever done anything like
that no i'd been a member of the
president's panel on educational
research and development in the kennedy
and johnson administration when i was
working in education and that was for
five years and that was the first monday
and tuesday of every month but that's
these were the two i've also been on
office of technology assessment panels
i've been in and out i've testified but
but this was this was a little different
um
and um
anyway so bill mckenna who was the
chairman came to me one of the last
meetings and said you know we'd like
people to be able to read the executive
summary we don't want it done in
bureaucracies it's about 50 pages would
you write it for us and i said yes but
i'm going to do that somebody has to pay
me for it uh because i just can't afford
it i got too little i got was that one
little kid and i and um
i cannot give you an enormous amount of
writing time and that's at least a
month's work a 50-page executive summary
but i tell you what i'll do i'll go to a
foundation
so the government doesn't have to pay
and i'll have the foundation give the
money to the department of housing and
urban development to pay to me for for
writing the 50-page summary as a
professional job you know he said
commissioners are not supposed to be
paid for their work on the commission i
said to him bill you're an snl lawyer
maury mann is is with merrill lynch
mortgage capital pete herter is a real
tour with the national association of
realtors and i ran down all the other
people on the commission every one of
you guys has party pre here every one of
you is representing clients or building
his own business we're working in this
and i haven't seen anybody give up his
own side of this in any of these
meetings i'm the only guy here who does
not make any money out of this industry
and who does not have any stake whatever
in what this
this commission says and you tell me
it's a conflict of interest for me to
get paid by a foundation for my time to
write the executive separate bill was a
very decent guy and his father was a man
who worked in the sewers and then and
and
he's he's he's not one of these
rockefeller types who thinks everybody
has enough money all the time thought
about it and he said you're right in
this case we could wave
what kind of money they paid to do
i think i got 7 000
um
it went through the smith richardson
foundation which was very acceptable to
the reagan administration um i had done
they had been people who were interested
with the sloan foundation in sponsoring
a possible television series for me
which had died and so i knew them i knew
the people there and i called them and i
said this is a job that they want me to
do and i really can't afford to give
this time away
um could you would you be willing to
make a grant to hud for hud to pay me
and they said sure they made the grant
to hud took her eight months to pay me
much but they but they did pay it was
either seven thousand dollars or seventy
five hundred dollars it was not that bad
it was not that bad a payment for the
time
the experience uh you saw government up
close of course you've done these other
things in government what do you think
of the process
i
i sort of like the constitution um i
think it could work a lot better than
it's than it's now working
uh somebody asked me a while ago what if
i could reform the government what's the
first thing i would do and i said sort
of one-third is a joke but two-thirds
not i would repeal the unified budget
act of 1921. there was no unified budget
in this country until twenty one the
departments of government submitted
their requests separately to the
congress and the congress had to make a
budget at them
we came out of the first world war when
that hadn't worked well the president's
involvement was as commander-in-chief he
submitted the the budgets for the armed
forces um but for the all the other
departments of government they did it
themselves and then congress made a
budget out of it that's what congress is
paid to do
um
the
you you moved from the budget bureau to
the office of management and budget to
the present situation where the
executive branch is trying to make all
these decisions and considers itself not
just one of the players but the prime
player that's not the way our
constitution is written the constitution
has written that money bills originate
in the house budgets are to be made in
the house the house
becomes irresponsible the government
becomes irresponsible when when parts of
it slough off to other parts what their
constitutional
responsibilities are um
in the case of of
you know in this in the in the s l
scandal i blame the media a lot to be
honest with you um
if if this story had been covered
if when an snl goes under big snl with
some degree of scandal if the press
published the name of their lawyers if
the press published the name of their
accountants if you know sunshine remains
the best disinfectant that's one of the
reasons i have all these names in this
book
i think you have to be responsible for
what you do i sign what i do
with all with all that's wrong with my
profession isn't a profession it's a
trade i sign it i get vice guys on the
front of my face you show the audience
that's it what this book looks like
this is martin mayer's book it's his
26th the greatest ever bankrupt at least
26 that we can count
the collapse of the savings and loan
industry
and speaking of uh you know my twenties
um mopes not used to say if you write
three pages a day it's a thousand pages
a year now he was better than i am but
26 books sounds like a lot of books but
there's a year or two in each of them um
uh how long have you worked on this book
i signed the contract in 88
about two years when did you write the
last word that we're reading well the
afterward was written in july there's a
there's a 12 page section at the end
which they gave me a chance to write at
the end comment about what had been
happening otherwise it was written i
guess in march let me read this the
books written on this subject this is
your book your words page 19. the books
written on this subject today have been
rather like the famous story of the
indian blind man describing elephant one
sees the mafia one sees the texas
cowboys infecting the whole country with
financial aids one sees regulators
goofing off one sees a malfunction from
the continuation of inadequate laws into
an era when they became destructive
all of this is true up to a point and of
course there's nothing wrong with
telling the stories which are great fun
in themselves what's different about
your book than just telling these other
stories like this because well i'm
dealing with the with the systemic
problem here at least i hope i am
um and you're saying they're accountants
and
lawyers
and elected officials there's something
deeply wrong with all those i'm saying
to begin with
the simplest way to tell what happened
here to say the government in 81 82 had
a very bad problem connected with five
with the financing of housing um
we had a lot of institutions that had
long-term mortgages that were yielding
six seven eight nine percent at a time
when these institutions had to pay for
new money anyway um
11 12 13
uh
a decision was made
that these institutions could grow out
of this problem they could add enough
very high yielding assets so that they
could pay on the marginal money enough
they could make money at the end of it
and they had a certain amount of money
that was still an endowment of five and
a half percent
past book savings
if you if you structured the world so
that they could get more money because
they could advertise higher interest
rates they could then make new loans at
even higher interest rates and make
enough money so they could make up for
what they were losing on the old one
and the industry could in general grow
out of it and when interest rates came
down a bit it would be profitable and
strong
this was a mistake
um
i am not going to criticize the people
who made the mistake it was a desperate
time i remember sitting around in these
meetings we were counting the number of
months until the whole industry went
bust and you couldn't save it anymore so
these accounting rigs that pratt put in
were for the purpose of enabling people
to hang on until they could grow out
dick pratt head of the federal home loan
bank board
but this was a mistake because the basic
problem in the snl industry was over
capacity
um
when we sat on the housing commission we
looked at how you finance housing i was
on the finance committee and one of the
things that jumped out of the historical
record
is that in the 1920s
and in indeed right after world war ii
20
plus
of home mortgages in the united states
were held by life insurance companies
and by 1980 they held no mortgages
meanwhile the savings of the country
were moving from a depository chassis
that is from deposits and banks and snls
to a contract chassis that is payments
to pension funds
life insurance companies mutual funds
so that and these people these
recipients of household savings were not
buying mortgages so we said we have to
design instruments
that will help the contract thrift as we
call them begin to get into housing
finance this will provide more money for
housing remember we're a housing
commission we have a parochial view and
it will provide that at lower cost which
everybody wants the american people will
be able to get better housing cheap what
was not in our month two things were not
in our minds
one was
that
we were going to be putting pressure on
what the s could earn
because they'd be competitive for buying
mortgages and therefore the spread
between the cost of money and what
mortgages got the spread between what
corporations had to pay in bonds and
what people who bought homes had to pay
in mortgages would be reduced and the
long-term viability of the industry
would diminish
because it would have more competitors
for its own business
and the second thing we didn't think
about was that we were structuring very
complicated instruments to bring in
these guys and the wall street house
would screw around with those
instruments for their own benefit so
that some of it would be junk and they
would and they would sell the junk to
the snl's and they would they would
trade bits of glass with the natives to
their own immense profit which is what
the wall street houses did they would
broker in the funds they'd get paid big
commissions for brokering in the funds
and then they'd sell them the
collateralized mortgage obligations and
different tranches and you don't want to
know the details but i give as little as
i can in the book because i think people
have to understand some of this
understand
what what happened but it's a very
complicated story so those things happen
meanwhile we had an industry that had
700 billion dollars of deposits its
social function was shrinking because
others were going to provide a lot of
the mortgage we said you can grow out of
it we grew it up to 1.4 trillion we're
lucky that the losses are only 170
billion it was a mistake you should not
have tried to grow this industry out of
its problems it had to shrink you had to
take some losses and shrink it we went
entirely the wrong way
in a capitalist system you couldn't grow
an industry that was failing but we
don't have a capitalist system in
banking we have a government guaranteed
system through deposit insurance
therefore the government could structure
things so that these guys could grow by
saying that we will we will guarantee
whatever interest you promised they
could grow
so the government set this up
the market would have killed these guys
if if if they'd a a free market snl's
would have failed money would have fled
the industry and the industry would have
shrunk willy-nilly with possibly great
damage to the so to the society the job
was to shrink it without damage instead
we grew it with immense cost
now by 1970 by 1984
it was pretty clear that this is what
was happening you could see the losses
building
credit of ed gray who was pratt's
successor at the bank board and if you
measured iq's is well below
dick pratt but he's a decent guy with
certain amount of common sense and and
and he cared about his job and he felt
responsible for what was happening by
the way let me interrupt to ask you dick
pratt left for what reason he went
he he had said he would serve two years
he went out to make money how did ed
greg get his job where'd he come from ed
gray had been ronald reagan's press
secretary when he was governor of
california and he had worked in the
reagan campaign when reagan became
president he became the first director
of the domestic policy group at the
white house then he went back to
california because his wife hated
um
washington he got a job with great
american savings and loan gordon loose
who was a friend of the president uh and
they wanted somebody who would not make
waves or disturb things to become the
head of the bank board after pratt and
who would keep all the pratt quote
reforms close quote in being and they
reached out for ed and ed was a little
flattered he had he had been a reporter
for the united press he'd been a radio
guy he'd been a speechwriter this was
going to be a chance to have executive
authority and a big job um
he took the job and he did the very best
he could with it and i admire edgar but
he never had experience with banking or
savings he never had experience with
running no he worked for an snl he
worked in the press department how long
did he stay at the federal home loan
bank he stayed his full term of four
years
um
he tried hard all right at some point in
the book you talk about he'd never run
anything you understand me that was part
of the problem also he had to organize
something for a new set of tasks he had
trouble doing that
he didn't have pratt's understanding of
this industry though it grew ed grew in
that job um and i i respect and i and
and i like uh john gray it is an honest
man a lot of people don't like it um
and when i when the wall street journal
said i was working on this book a lot of
people used to work at the bank board a
lot six of them got hold of me and said
don't let ed gray rewrite history but
the fact is that gray
began shouting that there were troubles
when it was very unpopular to do so he
tried to make changes he didn't know
which changes he wanted to make
um
he didn't handle it well in some ways
but he tried and he was an honest man
and i think he deserves a lot of credit
he's getting it now for once let me ask
you about something you said 170 billion
in losses because of the savings alone
in this book though you talk about where
charles bowser who's the comptroller of
the united states and ed gray sat around
betting how big this loss was going to
be yeah and ed gray said it was going to
be bigger than 500 billion no nobody
says the loss is 500 billion present
value present value it's maybe i say 150
i think it's now been seen
siemens handling the bailout so badly
it's now up to 170. and if we continue
running the resolution trust cooperation
the way we are we'll get to 200. very
soon too and maybe present value over
time if you tax people to pay it out now
it would be let's say 170 billion
dollars that's a lot of money um but if
you're going to borrow to take care of
it then you got to add in the interest
that you pay on the borrowings
so then let's assume it's eight percent
interest that you're going to pay
in nine years it doubles in 18 years it
quadruples by the rule of 72 so that
it's it's a question of what time are i
going to pay it back on how much
interest you're going to pay you can get
to 500 billion very easily if you want
to look at the year 2020 you can get it
up to 600 billion the present value of
the losses
what has been lost not what you're going
to pay interest on later but what has
been lost is probably somewhere between
150 and 200 though it may get worse
there's a lot more in this book and
we're running out of time and i want to
ask you about something that's in the
appendix it's appendix c in 1985
february the 13th you have a letter in
here from alan greenspan
um
it's about the lincoln savings and loan
association it's about charles keating i
want to ask you that on february the
13th 1985
what was the public knowledge about the
lincoln uh savings alone the public
knowledge was that the with the federal
home loan bank board had decided that
that direct investment by snl's was
dangerous
uh the the san francisco people who
supervised lincoln savings and loan had
found that mr keating had put far more
than the legal maximum into a into a
fight for the control of gulf
broadcasting that he had put money into
ivan bowsky that he had stopped writing
home loan home mortgages though he had
said he was going to the snl he had
bought was the largest supplier of
mortgages to the black and hispanic
populations of southern california he
had withdrawn from that business he had
closed his branches in lower middle
class neighborhoods and he was putting
money into very risky things his own
developments
golf broadcasting
boesky a lot of mike milken stuff for
drexel burnham and the bank board was
concerned about him and was trying to
rein him in
um
his his lawyer then was arthur lyman who
would presently become the lawyer for
the senate in the in the iran-contra
affair mr lyman and he recruited
before lyman professor george benson of
the university of rochester to do an
academic dissertation on why direct
investment was right and keating should
be left alone and this was considered by
mr lyman to be insufficient to persuade
the feds mr lyman went and paid alan
greenspan who was then a private
consultant forty thousand dollars
essentially to write a letter in keating
support to the federal home loan bank of
san francisco it would have been
possible i would say fairly easy to
determine that a number of the
statements in that letter were false at
that time okay alan greenspan is now the
chairman of the federal reserve very
competent what i would say i disagree
with this and that but alan is not a bad
guy the problem in this book is not the
people who are bad guys that doesn't
bother me you always get bad guys it's
what the good guys did because the
standards were like i just want to read
some of this because this comes from the
current chairman of the federal reserve
board at the time what a consultant i
don't know he was then a private
consultant whose services were for sale
but presumably he was an honest man all
right he writes a very sad letter i run
it with me okay yeah do it i have read i
have reviewed the application lincoln
has submitted to your office this is to
the office of the principal supervisor
agent federal homeowner bank board or
federal homeowner bank in san francisco
and it is my opinion that lincoln
clearly merits the exemption it seeks
one lincoln's new management and that of
its parent american continental
corporation is seasoned and expert in
selecting and making direct investments
two the new management has a long and
continuous track record of outstanding
success in making sound and profitable
direct investments three the new
management succeeded in a relatively
short period of time and reviving an
association that had become badly
burdened on and on and on all false
all false why
because he believed what his client told
him and that's because he didn't look he
was he was he was wrapping with the
mantle of his reputation somebody who
was a crook and a swindler that's what's
so troublesome is mr keating guilty of
anything
heating i think's going to wind up in
jail
um
he's a great con man well he stole 40
million bucks the last day before they
seized the institution 40 million
dollars moved out through bankers trust
to parts unknown
caribbean i think so why didn't he use
the money then to get him out when he
had a fight because he doesn't want to
admit he's got it i mean nobody knows
where that money went
nobody's subpoenaed bankers trust
records federal reserve board would have
a bleeding hemorrhage if anybody did but
we should um charlie charlie keating
was engaged in a large number of crooked
activities while he ran lincoln savings
alone
and you know he's been indicted now for
swindling these old people in california
he will be indicted again on federal
charges i think keating will eventually
go to jail um i think he should go to
jail you say in this book you talk about
accountants your name all the big
accounting for all the big accounting
all the big
law firms anderson did file stuffing for
keating but that's a matter of talking
about the whole premise you have here
then you name the chairman of the
federal reserve board
what is wrong with this country
that's the question the book asks in the
end do you have an answer
yeah
well there's a my favorite line in my
own book one always has a favorite line
and ones i would have a favorite book
but when i say your favorite line is
that the 1980s were a time when the
government conspired so that the pigs
could get what used to be the lion's
share
i have i have i i'm a believer in
capitalist economies i'm a believer in
markets
what we did in this i mean was jim it
was jim tobin of yale who first
described it i believe as socializing
the losses and privatizing the gains it
became the only standards of judgment we
seem to have by the time the 80s were
halfway through was how much money did
he
make there's been a there's been an
erosion of of moral fiber and ethical
sense in this country how you reverse it
i don't know but that's what's so
disturbing about it why did it happen
what's causing it
well i suppose
you know i was active in education in
the 60s and there was all this stuff
about never trust anybody over 30. and i
used to say to these kids when i would
travel around i traveled around for the
sloan found foundation and for some
others visiting colleges on various
studies that i would do i would say to
them you're right but you don't seem to
understand why um the generation that
came out of world war ii um the people
who had lived through the depression and
then world war ii felt they were going
to get theirs after the war they
structured the world on what is a very
unfair basis intergenerationally
um
the kids who were in college in the 60s
they the kids of the baby boom have been
cheated really they're not going to get
the social security that their parents
got they're not going to get a lot of
other things the whole way the the
seniority systems were set up in the
unions the way everybody protected
himself
and this came out of the
we're talking things far beyond
economics it came out of of i think the
experiences of the generation
that ran the
country finally in the 80s the people
who who who
turned
the age where they were in authority had
been brought up in an atmosphere of
graspingness
in the 50s
and i think that we have to blame that
more than anything else the question is
how do you turn it around
how do you
restore some notion of citizenship
in a country like this one and i don't i
would hope
book does well enough i'll have some
time to try to think about it and maybe
i'll have i'll have something worth
worth hearing on it when it's over
anything's possible i'm not sure i have
anything worth hearing on it now
um
but it's it's a serious problem i chewed
out some academics the other day
that there that the kids come out of the
business schools now with so little
sense of what constitutes standards of
behavior how much time do we have got
two minutes for a story
60 seconds 60 seconds this is this is
this is about a guy who said to me that
when he went to work on wall street
sometimes people would say to him we
don't do that that's what that's a deal
we don't do he said it's been 20 years
since i've heard anybody say say we
don't do that
we've got to get back to a sense of for
my self-respect i don't do that maybe
you can find somebody else to do it
maybe it isn't illegal but i don't do it
i have too much pride to to we're doing
losing that is the really dangerous
thing and that's really what this is
about
our guest for the last 60 minutes has
been martin mayer this is what the book
looks like it's published by scriveners
it sells for 22.50 you can find it in
your bookstores thank you sir thank you
[Music]
next week on notes we talk with captain
carol barcelo co-author of in the men's
house
captain barcelo will discuss her
experience as one of the first women
entering the u.s military academy at
west point back in 1977.
she will trace her military career from
her west point days to the present
and if you would like a printed
transcript of the previous program send
five dollars to tape writer incorporated
box 885 lincolnshire illinois
zero nine six
[Music]
wow
[Music]